- So I'm going to ask
you a few questions here.
- Okay.
- I want you to name a
number between one and 10.
Now, most people name seven.
- Oh.
- That's the number they name the most,
but you can name any number you want.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight nine, or 10.
- You want me to... Four.
- Four. You wanna change your mind?
- Nope.
- Sure?
- Yeah, I'm very certain.
- Okay. Want black or red?
- What?
- Black or red?
- Oh, red.
- Red. Okay, you wanna change your mind?
- No.
- Do you want diamonds or hearts?
- Diamonds, April. Hello.
- Diamonds?
- Yes.
- Wanna change your mind?
- No.
- You say the four of diamonds.
- Four of diamonds.
- Four of diamonds is what you've chosen.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You wanna change your mind?
- No.
- You're gonna think back on this.
You wanna change your mind?
- No.
- Okay.
Now I've got these three songs here.
Which one do you want there?
Name one of them.
- "Stronger".
- You say "Stronger".
- Yes.
- Okay.
- You ready, Teller?
Here comes "Stronger".
- Oh, okay.
(applause and cheering)
- We have two others here.
We got "Stronger" on the knife.
We got "A Moment Like This"
and "Piece by Piece" here.
(Kelly laughs)
It's amazing. Yeah.
- Now I want you to see this one here.
If we took this and cut it open, like so,
you would see in the middle of that,
you would see nothing but
citrus goodness there.
- Yeah.
- Now if we took this one,
"A Moment Like This" --
- Yeah.
- -- and cut this one open --
- Okay.
- -- you would see nothing in there --
- Oh, yeah.
- -- but citrus goodness.
But "Stronger" which
is the one you chose --
- Yeah. Oh my God.
If you think that a card is in...
If the four of diamonds
is in there, get out.